una nueva escalada de violencia se
activó entre Armenia y azerbaiyán la
noche del lunes cuando las tropas hace
10 iniciaron ataques a gran escala
utilizando artillería pesada y drones en
diferentes puntos de la línea de
contacto específicamente en la región
este de Armenia por su parte para
estabilizar esta situación Armenia apeló
a Rusia para implementar las
disposiciones del tratado de seguridad
colectiva y el consejo de seguridad de
la ONU por su parte en Moscú e hizo
reiterados llamados al cc al fuego sin
embargo fueron violados en todas las
oportunidades recientemente el Primer
Ministro de Armenia Nicole fascinan
anunció que Ya son varias decenas la
cantidad de soldados muertos y también
se han registrado civiles heridos ya que
las tropas a series también han tenido
como objetivo los asentamientos civiles
la situación en la frontera continúa
tensa
en un escenario que la parte Armenia
considera una invasión y una violación
al territorio soberano de su país